British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
says his government is suspending
Parliament until just two weeks before
brexit the suspension would give
lawmakers less time than expected to
debate Britain's exit from the European
Union on October 31st now Johnson has
denied criticism that he was trying to
prevent a debate as he said Parliament
would be back in session ahead of a key
EU summit that is completely untrue if
you look at what we're doing we're
bringing forward a new legislative
programme on crime on hospitals and
making sure that we have the education
funding that we need and there will be
ample time on both sides of that crucial
October the 17th summit ample time in
Parliament for MPs to debate the EU to
play brexit and all the other issues
let's go right to DWS burgomaster she's
standing by for us in London with the
very latest hi Berkut so Boris Johnson
now saying that he's going to ask the
Queen to suspend Parliament tell us what
this means
well Boris Johnson shows a lot of
determination to get reckless
brexit through we have to remember that
the 31st of October is the deadline this
is when Britain is going to leave the
European Union and Boris Johnson has
always maintained that this is going to
happen do-or-die he is fearing his
government the brexit ears and his
government are fearing that Parliament
can somehow influence the brexit process
and we've seen yesterday
opposition MPs coming together and
trying to come up with a plan in order
to prevent Britain just from leaving the
European Union at the end of October
without any deal with the European Union
and Boris Johnson's government wants to
say well we have a free hand we don't
want Parliament basically to to throw
anything in the spanner of the works
when it comes to leaving brexit of
course they maintain that this is a
normal process they are now saying they
are preparing a Queen's speech which is
a new legislation but on the other hand
it's not normal that Parliament is
suspended during times like this during
breaks at times when frankly every day
that Parliament is sitting counts when
it comes to shaping brexit record I want
to make sure I understand this correctly
does that mean the step that Boris
Johnson is taking that there would be no
way to stop a No Deal drags it on
October 31st for lawmakers in Parliament
well sue me that is really the big
question in any case it's very difficult
to stop the government in their ways
because the opposition MPs have so far
not being very strong they haven't shown
the same steel enos as Boris Johnson is
now showing so they were basically
trying to find some sort of consensus
some sort of way of coming together and
this is difficult because it's involved
in periods of many different parties and
they might also need to rely on
conservative MPs to help them so now
what it means is that I have much less
time to come up with anything and they
might resort to a vote of no-confidence
next week for that they definitely need
conservative MPs to help them and what
Boris Johnson is doing
just increasing the pressure on every
syde he's increasing the pressure when
it comes to his negotiations with the
European Union because he makes it much
more difficult for Parliament to prevent
an Odile brexit so he's saying we are
really really serious we are going to
live on the other hand he also leaves
Parliament very little time if he does
come up with a new agreement with the EU
if there's anything that can change then
Parliament will might have to just say
yes to it and then he might be able to
get this agreement with the EU over the
line but it's a really high-risk gamble
and there are many ways that this can
fail so he is really going for it and
opposition MPs are saying he's throwing
down the gauntlet to Parliament that he
was the leader of the leave campaign
which was all about Parliament taking
back control of us about the mother of a
parliament about the the birthplace of
democracy getting power back from the
European Union and now he is actually
suspending Parliament so that they
cannot disturb him in his way say that's
how the opposition MP see it so
basically we're going to see really a
war here in London when it comes to the
government and its relation to
Parliament Birgit we've seen online
already some reactions saying this is a
dark day for democracy tell us more
about the reactions to all of this there
in London well from all sides opposition
MPs have said have expressed their
outrage actually and exactly with you
know the same arguments they said we are
the we are Parliament we are sovereign
and you can't just suspend us and for
example a former government minister
Rory Stewart he was on the radio this
morning they said he actually didn't
think that Boris Johnson would dare
anything like this to do anything like
this that was us for you know as close
as this morning but he said if Boris
Johnson if the government does do this
does suspend Parliament and we're just
going to meet somewhere else and we are
not going to get stopped so they will
try everything they can and they have to
act quickly now in order to to prevent
the government from basic
the disabling them alright our
correspondent Burgert mas with the very
latest there in London where the prime
minister says he has asked the Queen to
sassette suspend Parliament until
October 14th burger thank you for that
update